thank you very much thank you everybody
for coming
I'm especially like to say a big thank
you to then it's come for inviting me to
come and speak and I really want to say
a huge thank you to the volunteers I'm
sure we all do it's been a fantastic
conference they've put a lot of hard
work and for you know the considering
that they'll do it all in their spare
time I think that's fantastic so thank
you to the conference good job okay so
today I'm going to spend an hour and 40
minutes talking you through material
that should probably take two days
normally so it's going to be quite a
packed agenda I'm going to assume you've
got no knowledge of Dhaka so I took it a
very basic level about what docker is
why you'd want to use it I don't need to
do some basic terminology so this is one
of the things I found very confusing was
what's the difference really contain an
image so we'll get that cleared up
straight away and some other terminology
as well and then actually hopefully
spend most of time actually sat using
docker and getting some practice at
using it okay
now I've tried to put in here the things
I found confusing over the last sort of
18 months or so that I've been using
docker so hopefully you won't have the
same frustrations that I will so we're
in a forest there are many trees and I'm
going to hopefully lead you through a
path let me say that you won't have your
own frustrations because you'll be
following your own path after that but
hopefully you won't you won't hit the
same potholes I did so we're going to
look at what docker is why it's useful
and then just how to use it
and I want you to be confident enough
when you go away from here you can carry
on because there's a whole lot of things
we can't do we won't have time to do
I've got more material than we can cover
so I hopefully you'll we want to take
away what I've written and just carry on
using it and then and then take it
further there are things that we can't I
can't talk about just because of lack of
time and complexity so docker security
is quite a big topic we won't be talking
about networking if you are from a
DevOps environment you're used to terms
like you've hearing terms like
kubernetes and swarm we won't be talking
about this this talk is for
docker at the small-scale it'll be
particularly useful if you are a
developer or tester if you're going into
a DevOps environment you will still need
to understand this material though to
build on top of it and I won't be able
to go into every single gory detail and
every command option there's lots of
them so you'll need to have the
documentation open in front of you while
we're working okay whoops wrong way okay
so hopefully everybody can do this from
the command line is anybody not able to
do this alright so you should be able to
just flip over to a shell and go doc
version and then go docker container run
hello world who can do that
if you're on Linux then you add you
could you could either keep doing sudo
which is a bit tedious but the solution
is to add yourself to the docker group
and then log out and log in again and
you'll have the permissions you need all
the material here I here is in this
github repo you'll probably want to
clone this repo now because when we
start doing exercises a lot of exercises
of pre-written so all the materials in
the repo is going to type in the
commands and there's a git er community
which I've got open so if you want to
join that and ask any questions either
now or in the future please do so why
don't just hit escape it does good
yeah the discovery of mine yesterday so
it was quite good I'll just make a
shutdown the Year slideshow
okay so but about me so I've been using
Linux for a long time I actually started
I actually organized the first Linux
conference in the UK back in 98
I think so I was a minute I'm a mini
musty rustling that respect that
currently workers at in developer
relations that a software house hidden
in Melbourne called paper cut soft wave
actually pay for me to come here and
also the my colleagues help me refine
and rehearse this material so very many
things to them back in Australia I
really like technology in all its sort
of various forms perhaps sometimes a bit
too enthusiastic and I'm a keen consumer
of coffee and craft beer you can contact
me on all the usual places as well if
you afterwards so whatever why did I
come to docker so a few years ago you
know doc docker became very popular we
was talking about docker but it was very
hard to work it was going on and I got
very frustrated going to what was
supposed to the introductory discussions
about docker and there was explain to me
why I would use it and what problems I
could solve and sort of the basic ideas
and that's so I've always been conscious
that it's important to start from that
when talking about docker and sort of
what is the difference between a
container an image and until you've got
those basic understandings it doesn't
make much sense so that's very much my
objective in delivering this sort of
sort of talk is to try and get people
bootstraps into that so he talked to
people about docker you get words like
just you know what's dr. well it's it's
all these things and people use various
phrases but if you actually look at that
as a phrase on its own it doesn't really
mean any much fruit doesn't mean very
much so let's talk in a bit of detail
about what docker muck what sort of
problems docker might solve so I've got
a simple model of an application which
should be familiar to most people so
we've got the concept of an application
or a service and it's a collection of
processes a run on a computer and the
resources that they need to actually get
useful work done so a process is a
software piece of software it's loading
as memory and running it's a single
single process and the process has
access to resources so there
the resources are all the things
external that you need to actually do
useful work obviously things like files
and data in the files but also
permission to access networks security
profiles and so on and so forth yes that
should be all pretty simple and there's
you know a sort of picture of it of
multiple processes accessing different
resources to make something that's
useful okay so how could you run that
well the obvious thing you could have a
bigger machine was an operating system
and you just run all these different
processes on the machine and the
operating system controls access to the
resources it's a nice simple model it's
got some problems processes can just one
process can consume all the memory and
starve all the other processes of
resources or you have to buy a big
enough machine with enough Headroom to
cope with peak capacity which is a waste
and so on and so forth so there's a lot
of capacity issues with that sort of
thing it's also a complex environment to
recreate for development or testing and
not practical so there's a variety of
issues and of course one process yep
I feel early on linux you have to type
sudo unless you make yourself I remember
the docker group so then in the 1998
1998 got virtual machines so in virtual
machines were carving up the computer
into partly into different areas and
they're protected by having their own
copy operating system so that's the
difference as multiple copies of
operating system running each process is
completely isolated from its neighbor I
can only get resources given to it to
give them to its guest operating system
that did a lot and the you know PM's are
very popular still but they have
problems they're actually quite complex
to provision and manage and it's hard
it's still hard to actually run up the
same configuration to test and
development as you do to production ok
it's slow to start up you know I'll take
it if you having to boot if you have
started process and it means booting of
VM it takes a finite amount of time
several minutes in fact to boot up and
of course if you're using licensed
software then you've got multiple
licensing costs as well now as an aside
we're talking to talk about
containerization and that does not mean
that the M disappears to the place with
VM technology in the operational
environments I don't think that vm's are
going away because they're not they're
just changing their role slightly ok so
then we come to the concepts for
container so a container is a similar
model to virtual machines but we remove
all the guest operating systems so each
of those processes is actually accessing
the Linnet underlying Linux operating
system here the difference is is that
container layer is mitigating or is
managing that connection and these
controlling the access to resources ok
so each of those processes thinks
they're actually running the separate
machine even though they're not they
can't see themselves they can't see one
process that can only see once it's set
of users are given access to they can't
consume more resources than they'd be
given access to this type of thing so
there
to be in a box in a container okay but
it's not perfect it's can be harvest
once you got it ranked working you're
running it's very quick and easy to run
generally but it's actually fairly
complex to set up and test and that's
one thing you make sure it's resilient
and if you are going to do this at scale
then you start to read need to real or
react you take some of your applications
to use things like micro services so
typically when people think of docker or
containerization I think in macro
service architectures but a lot of the
applications the world and of course is
not micro service based so having got
sort of those ideas out then if you look
at the more formal definition from
Wikipedia of of containerization then it
starts to make sense it got we've got
this concept of containers which contain
processes that look like real computers
to the presses inside them but in fact
or not they're just effectively a box in
which you can in theory escape out of
them which to which you have granted
certain resources and and so that there
are isolated from each other so does
that all that makes sense
yeah oh by the way please do free feel
free to ask questions I may not be able
to able to answer all of them but I do
my best and if not I can take things
offline and answer them later okay yes
yes I mean that if zero is one of the
mechanisms views or multiple kernel
mechanisms that are used to provide this
facility and I'll give you a reference
later so you can just have a ball so
what's the benefits of this scalability
it's quick and easy to start these
workers you're not so you're not saying
guest operating system you're starting
one or two or three processes so it
takes milliseconds to bring up a new
container if it container crashes you
can restart it very quickly and easily
if a container the container is
constrained so it can't in theory run
amok
and and just take overall everything
else of the Machine lower costs you
don't have multiple copies of your
operating system you can see them a lot
less memory so where you could maybe
have three virtual machines you can have
10 or 100 containers that's a huge
saving and it's now reasonably easy to
make your dev and testing rama's look
like production depending on your dev
environment that's not universally true
but for a lot of developers and this is
the attraction they they can they can
quickly spin up something that's got the
same dependencies in the same
architecture albeit at a smaller scale
that's production and it makes it much
easier for them okay okay so so docker
is a technology and it's a company and
they provide and the docker product
provides you the containerization so
containerization the generic term if you
look on the Wikipedia page of referenced
earlier there are lists of other docker
to other docker sorry other
containerization products are they have
been around for some time dock is not
the first one there were doctors the
most well-known them and the one that
people are using the most now it
specifically worked on Linux kernel back
in the day now the ability to run docker
on Windows I'm not gonna talk about that
I don't know much about it and this is
an its conference anyway okay there's a
really good video here that I recommend
by Liz Rice which actually shows you how
to build containerization technology
from scratching go so it actually
explains how its kernel can run these
containers and the facilities that
docker depends upon to make that happen
so that's quite good
and because docker is so popular there's
lots of material out there to help use
lots of tools for orchestration like
kubernetes or swarm there's lots of
training courses there's talks at
conferences there's books there's videos
and so on ok so you get lots you can get
you can get get up quickly
any a question so for us all making
sense yes
okay so they work on top of Dockers so
what I'm just going to show you today is
just running docker at the small scale
so starting one two or three fourths
single application stuff things like
well Orchestra there so kubernetes and
swarmer examples of orchestration
frameworks so they allow you to run
hundreds of thousands of containers so
often people talk about pets versus
cattle so today we're going to be
treating our containers as pets with
individual individual ones we care about
them we take care of them when you're
running a hundred thousand you don't
care if one drops off the machine you
just start up another one so the ability
to start these machines at scale or
start you know these containers at scale
monitor them and manage them that's why
you use an orchestration framework okay
to very poor piece of terminology docket
images so a docker image is the sort of
the underlying concept of something you
need and all its got in it is a bunch of
files and some metadata and it should be
as small as possible people can exercise
making it really really really small
sometimes you know it's exactly
unproductive it's like over over
optimizing your code but it doesn't
contain a Linux kernel it's just the
additional files you need besides the
kernel to make your system work
certainly have things like things
packages in it that you might need if
you need to copy or cut fuel your
application might be in there it'll
obviously have your your your compile
programs they can run many configuration
files that might be needed and then the
metadata about what sort of resources it
needs what networking connections and so
on and so forth and it contains a
default startup command so that when the
container starts the default command
kicks off and the health the whole thing
is running the important thing about an
image is it's at rest it's on the disk
it's not a running process okay
compared to a container so containing
them is where you take an image off the
disk and you instantiate its contents
into it into a running container okay so
it's actually running it's it's it's
it's in flight it's going and a
container will contain at least one
processor obviously it usually contains
more than that but as few as possible is
ideal and you can start you can use an
image to then start as many containers
as you want so if you have a micro
surface type architecture then you can
order a low balancing architecture you
can just keep adding more containers
from the same image to scale your your
capacity horizontally now an important
thing which is kind of surprising to
people when they first come across is
that a container does not modify the
underlying image so if I start up a
container from an image and the
container rights to its file system and
I shut down the container that those
changes are gone there's nothing
preserved
okay the image is guaranteed to always
be the same each time yes so I'm saying
that when the container starts up it has
a virtually basically has a virtualized
file system it's a virtualized copy of
the image and it can update that it can
update that that container file system
but when you shut down and remove the
container that file system disappears
and you all you're left with is the
original image now I don't talk about
later on about how you actually do
preserve file system changes but it's
outside of the image okay that's that
first ability right so if you have an
image it will always be the same your
guarantee it's not going to change if
you start it start raining from an image
today it's gonna be the same as it was
yesterday no no no change okay
and the important thing to note is that
the working application will often
consist of multiple containers connected
to each other in various fashions to
make a working system and so the magic
phrase to remember is you build images
and you run containers if you keep that
in mind your life will be much happier
yep makes sense okay right let's
actually start doing stuff at the
command line
so let's actually get an image to run so
the first thing I wanna do is to
actually pull an image from docker hub
and the way you do that you need to go
doc is that font big enough yeah sure up
the back you see it's up the rack yes
good so docker container if you've got
if you're installed the command
completion by the way so if you come
that works on Mac and Linux I don't know
about Windows but you hit the tab key
with enough characters you do get and
you've got completion installed it will
work so go doctor to container pull
alkyne and I did something wrong because
its course docket image pulled off at UC
opportunies for every year and I still
get confused wieners and images because
of the way I got my system said I went
if I want to fix this because they're
always doing it he's wanted me to log
into to hub I don't think most of y'all
have that problem I already had it
pulled down so it didn't actually do
anything except check the shot yes John
it does yes so you have a you have a
local library so I have duck a client
installed here not that's all well has
it got docker engine but but I'm using a
doctor client and doctor Engine so when
I I have a local library of images and
he's just pulled that image into that
library yeah so it's not anything that
it's just sat there and I actually look
at it so if I go docket image LS I've
actually got quite a few images and I
have a laser pointer there is my Alpine
image that was and it was built by
somebody else four weeks ago I didn't
build that
I'm putting it for a place called hub
docker comm which is a website it's the
world's biggest website of images are
thousands and I have for Apple which
you'll be putting you'll be putting
images from my docker hub account later
on it's a bit like github in that
respect in its place where projects can
put images for other people's to use so
if I've got an image I can actually look
in it so if I go docker image inspect
don't worry about this too much because
we been doing up you go and do an
activity we do all this in a minute
inspect Alpine latest and that's
combined command completion others only
back type ILP hit to have any filled in
everything else for me that's really
quite useful and I get lots and lots of
information which I'm not going to take
you through but you can actually inspect
all sorts of things well you can expect
images you can expect containers when
they're running you can spent networks
which are integrating in straight
volumes so they've all got this method
this is the method director I talked
about only on image has metadata this is
the metadata from an image and something
useful things are for instance the show
that the command well as a shadow that's
you see the shadow the command it will
run is under that CMD heading
in the container configuration stands up
yeah and it's also the path it uses and
so on but I'm not look at in detail now
okay right let us do some work if we
should be able to go to the workbook on
github and hopefully you can start doing
tasks one to eight yep do you know where
I mean if I go yeah doc for novices so
here and then if you go to the wiki
section here as a workbook
so you two will duel you will pull from
Dhaka I've been not able to find that
No
yeah like the gig here so that's that's
Thiam that's the workbook
yes oh yes sorry my mistake
I didn't update that slide my apologies
that's that that's the URL you can read
that let me just quickly update that
we've gone too far I have lots of slides
most of which I hope not to show why is
this so slow
I can't edit the slides for the moment
just try and really off there you can't
read off there let me know
Oh
good tips Thank You anybody lost
sorry
yes yeah if you trust me yeah certainly
can you can just so I did the pool I did
the inspect as a better version of the
inspect command here so you actually get
out so that's the way I'm actually
extracting a specific information from
the inspector because it's all JSON so
you can use a JSON format to extract the
information right I can actually run it
so that is a container shell prompt so
I'm actually inside a container so if I
go PS I've only got two processes
running one is the shell that's running
in the container and the other ones the
PS command the running on top of that if
I look okay I get the whole thing it
behaves slightly differently under under
Mac and Linux
what else could anyway that's the one in
container
you should read the notes about the IT
option by the way that's pretty pretty
important and directionally if you
actually look at this so if you go
docker contain content LS - a that out
that containers still running in fact
there but they're all still running so
you actually got to type in an extra
command which is docker container RM and
now if you do a delicacy it's gone now
I'd actually start hello world a couple
of times so I need to get rid of those
as well so an alternative to using the
name is to use the ID which is this
magic char number like 5 5fb
so if i do that
I've lost both women oh yeah I've got
rid of one of them and if I do the other
one
so I had a to tide the Isle of
containers missing yeah it's okay so
it's like in okay first of all here's a
tip you often hear people talk about how
registries and repositories and repose
in Dhaka are just like get lab and it's
not true or github it's not true
they are there are some similarities but
they are different enough to be
confusing so don't use that model having
said that they every image and every
land every version of every object
pretty much in docker has one of these
unique IDs which is basically a char I
can use a simple technique as long as
you type enough to be unique it will
know what you're talking about so I
probably use the first two or even the
first one yep
you get nothing
that is because glad you asked that I've
got a demonstration of that sorry what
was your question
okay I'll demonstrate that right now the
same same question okay so what I
haven't talked about I don't and it's in
the slides but I'm not going to talk
about in the startling just demonstrate
it
he's a thing called the container
lifecycle okay which is part of what
you're doing so I actually have a script
that shows some of this off so so what
I'm doing now is I ran through a series
of docker commands with some technical
explanation of what they mean and I also
explained limits so the first thing
we're going to do is that we're going to
run the docker container called Alpine
and instead of it being interactive I'm
going to use the minus D option it's
going to go into the background and just
do some work so just sit there okay and
what that does is it actually runs a
little script fragment that just prints
out an integer every every five seconds
so it's giving me back again going back
to this idea that everything in docker
has a unique number there's the full
char for that container so it's actually
quite long okay now because the
container is running I can run docker
container LS yeah and it tells me the
container ID it can tells me the image
it came from it tells me the command
it's currently running which is a while
loop when it's created and it's status
okay so this is important this is is up
being up to 25 seconds okay
it also has a name it generates a ret if
you don't give it a name it generates a
random name which we can't see because
it's scrolled off to the right and okay
now do you ever I didn't inspect of an
image I can also do an inspector of a
container so I can see so as well as
image having metadata when it's actually
just on the disk
once the containers running it also has
metadata and I can look at that with the
inspect command so if I hit an expected
finders get loading as a JSON scrolling
for the top so if I pipe it through less
it's a bit more useful
I can see the image it came from I can
see the command it's running so if you
look at the top there there's the actual
while loop that's going on they've got
the pass to it and there's a bunch of
other information which we won't bother
looking at right now
that's quite tedious so here's a version
of the inspect command that uses and
another one these format modifiers to
actually just extract a single piece of
information in this case it's the status
so the status is running okay so we went
to not running to running I can now stop
the container so I should have stopped
command so I stopped container stop name
of name of my container not because I'm
a right image the name of my container
okay
that will take a few seconds because
runs a while loop going has actually got
a kill the while loop so I think issues
a kill and then eventually gets bored
and issues a kill nine or something
that's documented somewhere okay and so
we had to stop now the thing to note is
if you do docker container LS again you
get nothing the list is empty but if I
do the inspect command against there's
the same inspect command to just get the
status the status is exited and if I run
docker container LS - a which is what
this is about to do then it's actually
in the list we just didn't appear unless
we put the - a in because it status is
now exited so it's still in memory no
file system change has been thrown away
that logs are still there I could look
at the logs
I could I could reattach to it and start
fiddling with it I can read I could
actually start it again which I'll do in
a minute so it's still it's to the it's
still a chunk of allocated process space
albeit one that's not doing anything ok
it's in a special of docker state so if
I run the start command I can crank it
up again
so you see what
mm-hmm any better that Swiss
yeah I haven't maximized if I can't I
can't pull it back but no cause if I'd
maximized it I do that
although sorry you're right
ah damn yo thanks that
why is that still let me close like
right so I just rang container starts so
the exact city that I've now ran start
it's come back up again and the status
is off the bottom of the screen so right
sorry the SEC is now running okay and
now it's running I can actually attach a
terminal to it so remember it was in
Demon's right it was in detention Road
so if I go attach mcalpine that's right
in my Alpine I'm now attached and now I
can start seeing these numbers coming
out so it's been sat there for 22 times
five seconds running except for time
it's the suspended it's just hitting
numbers so I've hit control-c because
I'm bored it will finish so now because
it was attached to terminal and I've
killed the process that was running
inside it through the terminal it's gone
back to exited so I didn't actually have
to do stop because I hit control-c
inside the inside it it's gone too
exited why why is these notifications
coming so now actually so now that if I
to actually get rid of the site yeah so
now it's stopped I actually need to
remove it okay so if you stop it if you
stop a container it's not enough you
actually have to remove it and you
remove it with the RM command so it
stuck a container RM and now if I do
talk of container LS minus a that lift
is truly empty and if I do the status
command this is what I can't find I
can't find that containers view the
status command on so to do the inspect
command so it actually just gives an
error okay yeah if you want to if you
haven't stopped a good potato and you
want to remove it you can use the minus
F
but like in Linux file systems - f is to
be used with care so let's get our life
cycle so if you carry on through those
tasks that will actually give you
practical experience of of use of
hopefully understanding that I feel that
out of the two questions up this sign
about about that there's a control PQ
option which I've never got to work
successfully yeah you can D there's an
exact options you can actually if you
have a run in container that's doing
something or other you can actually
start a new shell on it and inspect it
is going on that's with the attach come
out good question that's worth
remembering attach I remember it's in
the workbook or not one thing I didn't
say is that we have far more material
that we can cover that if I mention that
so I don't expect you to finish all the
tasks and before we have to move on to
the next slot because we are short of
time
so I not well because it's not the
prices running
oops I accidentally got the stream going
I have such an ego I have to watch my
own livestream
so everybody happiness anybody lost no
good is this useful information learning
stuff good get some thumbs up at the
back
yeah
honestly I still do it wrong
thanks I hope you have exited really
because you I was just yeah because it's
in the background so I'm just starting a
shell so you have to give it a command
to run you've got it that's it oh hang
on they haven't so you've started it so
you've now got to you can now exec as
you can type instead type now just to be
six yeah yep oh no battery at work
that's a no tribe
Sh yep okay do a so what's your status
you've exited you shit's not running
yeah do do start use a stock event yep
you got me the sh the popcorn error okay
so how did you start it no no how did
you start it original you put it want to
kill it and start it again
so do it dr. RM remove double rim
container ID
so go okay so now now now do the
original docket contain around come on
let's see how you did right that
actually doesn't stay around that's
that's that doesn't it just prints out
hello world in exit exits you want to be
running Alpine yeah yeah Alpine is the
image that will give you a shell by
default yep yes PS vs. Ellis yeah but
you can do you something if you do dr.
PS minus Q a you will get just a lists
of identify useful
so I use that to feed it into other
thing like dokuro ring okay so don't
forget to RTFM green this read the fine
manual there's a lots of documentation
on so probably a little aside here
docker is an evolving product so things
change quickly but one of the reasons
you want to be on a reasonably modern
version and the documentation doesn't
always follow or is a bit patchy the
good news is neat buttons if you see
something you actually go on the website
and edit their Doc's so if you do see
something I encourage you to do that but
information can be repeated in multiple
places and so and so forth so thanks for
the practice but there's lots of
information there it's gets a bit
tedious typing all these commands so
shell alias is your friend there's an
example here throughout the rest of this
workshop the workshop notes and and I
will use these aliases at the bottom
they're quite useful but you can create
quite sophisticated aliases and I've put
a couple of links in the further reading
section with with links to people who've
posted lots and lots of very complex
aliases yes you could but you kit you
can do you can do yep but it's easier
just trade yourself with the docker
group log back in log out and log back
in again
if you're a Mac or Windows even here on
Linux oh okay I miss you I thought it'd
be the other way because would usually
do these things people running on Macs
and Windows so the problems are slightly
different so nobody's running docker
machine yes fantastic documents lightly
different doctor machine so doctor
machine is useful for two people firstly
people who have platforms that don't
support the current docker deployment on
Mac you know that it's a sort of default
deployment so if you've got an older
version of Windows or an older version
of a Mac or so on then use docker
machine because that depends on
VirtualBox so it using different
technology the other reason for using
docker machine is because allow you to
deploy to any machine so because it
works with things like VirtualBox if
you're into provision machine a
different machine you can use document
in from your workstation however in the
new release of docker like 18:09 they've
introduced an SSH facility so it's not
clear to me still why'd you use docker
machine but I'm not a systems
administration guy so I'm not an expert
so don't don't take anything I say
seriously on that regard
no no because you're still running
binaries yeah so you know you're still
making system calls you're still running
on a hardware from the so analytics box
because there's nothing you've said
between you and the hardware on the next
box it you're effectively the process
that's running inside the container is a
normal process so it still gets CPU
cycles it's still managed by the kernel
but it's just it's just controlled by
the generalization layer you can run
docker on PI by the way there are things
to do that
sorry yeah there's a lot in the
instructions Oh bear hedge boy I made
the rookie mistake dressed he'll make
all the time which is - I - team sorry
yeah it's yeah
okay I might I might press on if that's
okay so because we've done that we don't
need to we don't we don't need to go
through a lot of these slides yes
I'm sure your police's under some I am
these I will update this fight because
all these links are slightly wrong
because I moved all stuffers mark that
like the geek I moved into doctor or
novices we talked about that okay let's
talk about network ports so I talked
about the fact that all these containers
are isolated right which means they
can't write the network they can't they
can't write two disks they can't do
anything well they can't they can do
stuff but they can actually do anything
the information or they can't get new
information so so we have to fix that
because otherwise they're useless so we
need to find very controlled ways of
exposing information sinks and sources
to the container and one of the ways to
do that is to give them access to a
network port okay yeah
you use what's called port mapping it's
also called publishing so bit a bit of
mix up your terminology you'll see it
referred to in both and docks but the
idea is is that a specific port on the
container is exposed to the outside
world on another port on the engine box
okay so for this example here I'm
running the nginx I'm running the nginx
web server okay and nginx by default
publishes on port 80 so inside the
container
the Internet's process is listening on
port 80 for stuff and what this - -
publisher option does is say okay so
inside the container it's port 80 on the
outside to the outside world it's bought
808 9 and anything that comes in on a
ti-89 will get sent to the container on
port 80 yeah I did want a brighter
picture for this one didn't have time so
that makes sense yeah so that means that
you can just take this we have it don't
don't worry about doing the same example
because of the reserved as an activity
to do this which is different so if I
just run this container it's actually a
download the the image doesn't very long
I wrote all these examples to work
really fast across poor conference Wi-Fi
it turns out our Wi-Fi is really good
but means of sylvans really crossed yep
all of them zero zero zero zero yes good
question right so come on start up oh
all interfaces so you can connect now so
you can connect into this machine on put
all right
oh wait at nine and you'll get you'll
get to the engine xbox I did run it in
daemon mode so it's blocked never mind
that is why we have bottom tips so now I
can just hit that end point whoops
and there's the default nginx indexation
alpha yeah make sense so here's a tip I
used to I could never work out I could
never work out which way around those
numbers win so what I do is I remember
that it's it's outside and then inside
when I draw an arrow but you know going
from the outside to the inside and that
applies to the volume command as well or
they will be using mount which doesn't
quite work that way but but if you see
publish or minus P or you see volumes or
things like that and you can't work
remember which is which it's always this
is the outside on the left and the
insides on the right and the information
is going from one to the other but
pneumonic helps I'm going to say no it's
so what you do is the on the metadata
you say I'm going to publish report 18
but you can only specify which port at
runtime so you actually have to include
that line yeah I know what you call it
nothing I'm not a good enough Network
going thank you there you go
now if he's not the same as docker
networking okay I did so I wouldn't talk
about networking so I'm now going to lie
one of the things we won't be doing is
we'll be sitting at the dock container
network so you can actually set up a
whole networking infrastructure inside
the docker engine and across docker
engines they've got multiple machines
all running docker containers which you
need for application you can set up all
these virtual networks between them but
that's outside the scope and not
something I know a huge amount any about
anyway okay but this is this is port
mapping and that is really common so
it's so common that we've got an
exercise to do it task 9
so what I'm this is a completely
different example of actually written an
API server that you can run and hit and
the source code and all the docker build
stuff is all in that repo so it's not
some I mean when you run it it's just
going to work but what you can then do
later on is go back and look at how I
set it up and built it which is the real
value you're just cutting pasting stuff
doesn't actually teach you in yes you
can but using a pretty different
mechanism so there are various options
to do sound and things but yeah I've
never used them dude yes yes
I don't know how but I'd be surprised
that didn't work because you know this
stuff's used at scale so how would you
work in the scaling robbery you couldn't
do it I don't bloody know how good
question
anybody stuck
sorry okay
so stop it you should really just go RM
minus F and kill them no not docket kill
it's doc RM minus RF remove - firsts
okay anybody not finished
I have a bad knee so excuse me first sit
down
I wrote to my wife that I was feeling
nervous so she's it's not going to be on
that YouTube
okay I think I killed it okay can i yep
yeah yes you can do you can do that
because you the doctor demons running
with root privilege it's just people
don't usually do it but yes you can you
can map 18 so what you also quite come
and see is 80 to 80 so people put 80 on
both sides like : well it will do
something what are you running on 80 but
yeah sorry
[Music]
okay cut press on so file storage so
that's kind of weren't the major missing
pieces they had you had you sort of read
and write files databases configuration
files whatever the correct way to do it
is to use volumes so this diagram is not
fantastic but the idea here is to show
that volumes are made controlled by Daka
so what you do is that you say I want to
create a volume and docker will create
the volume for you and it will mount it
into the filesystem of the container and
every time the system read and writes so
the container read and writes to that
value to that mounted filesystem it will
be it will it will go to the volume and
then the volume persists beyond the
lifetime of the container okay
mounts are sort of the same thing but
different
so amount is a directory that you say to
docker here's a directory and I want you
to mount it into the process into the
into the docker container so it's not
it's not a question of saying you're
doctor please create me a volume and
manage it it's here as a directory just
mount it so if you're a developer that's
really useful because that you can put
your source code and stuff on that bring
up your development container and start
working and whichever little exercise to
do that but a volume is different so if
you've got a database file your so write
to doctor and again we've got exercise
this docker I want a database directory
you manage it and to back that up and to
manage it use other docker containers to
create your tar files or whatever the
backups okay so you it and it's it's
squirreled away somewhere inside the
docker file system you don't have to
worry about it but with amount you have
to worry about it now the reason I'm
talking about this is because volumes
are very clearly what you should be
using in production environments
you should not be using mounts now
possibly some use cases where that's not
true
but generally using a mount in a
production environment or even perhaps a
QA environment is a bad smell if you're
a developer then the only things that
should be in your mount points are
things at your source code that don't
need to move with the container okay
they're just things you need to use
whilst you're using container
so DIF obvious so not obvious but you
know does it make sense yeah okay so
okay things ism so here's an example so
this example is a bind Milt
so that diagram is actually slightly
wrong it should say a bind mount and
dative on you so here we have a
containers running its the nginx
container again and I'm buying mounting
the nginx HTML folder into a local that
example is incorrect I apologize it's
wrong that should that should say volume
not burned so what I'm saying here and
yeah ignore that as a byte this is it
correct very melt this example should
say volume which is bind and this is a
volume is managed by Daka
so what I'm doing is I'm saying to
docker please create a manager volume
for me and when this container starts
map that space to the HTML directory for
nginx okay and that means the contents
of the of the HTML documents are
preserved those are the type who knit
and of course we've still got the
publish this one is a mount now a part
of the fact that type is different where
it says bind it should assert volume in
the previous one the only difference is
the way that names specified so if you
notice where as a source is I actually
put a directory name not an
I put the put the name the value of a
directory path not the name that that
will something to be created over so you
can do two examples 10 11 don't fight
any questions about that before we carry
out we depend they're both good question
it wasn't now one thing that I emphasize
in the workbook and I'll just do this
verbally is you guys here I'm using - -
mount so let's - let's do the correct
example - - mount when you go on the in
the big wide world when I let you loose
all the examples you'll see used - V
instead - V doesn't doesn't use that
format it just uses source and
destination and the only way you can
tell the difference is the fact that for
a bind for a for a bi mount it's a full
directory path and for a volume it's a
name and missing and all you do is
missing that forward slash at the front
to tell you it's the directory path so
it's really not really easy thing to
miss so this is now the preferred the
preferred format but you will
undoubtedly see majority of people using
the - - volume option or the - V option
which doesn't specify it explicitly
layer explicitly like this yes no it
does map you can discover with where the
directory is but it's not a director you
have to worry about because like I said
when you actually want come to need to
back it up or you know or copy it to
move it then you say - docker ok please
copy this stuff out for me - standard
output and I will then put it into a tar
archive or whatever No
won't be hard to do but yeah it's not
the way it's meant to work yep any
questions let me do exercise of us ten
eleven
anything that doctor crates for your
three different networks but you don't
care about this
so I could repeat the questions the
question was was there any special
containers or or images or stuff or
volumes that docker creates for you
shouldn't delete and the answer is no
the a thing is docker crates is three
different networks and you can you can't
delete those
anybody finish this yet I hope so yes
you can add extra parameter to the Mount
come up to the mount option to make it
read-only greatly correct yep
I'll sit painful so why not faucet off
because I'm
was actually a small bhujette in the
instructions so if you go to file set be
so mad I can't your directory like it
says you should do in the workbook oh
hang on no it doesn't sorry
I miss you read my instructions that's
that's now running so if I go so in
here's my example code so I go they were
about to do that cuz I'm gonna go sir oh
dear there's a bug
is ever having trouble with the exercise
every spot the bug
I had no idea of scale there were people
who turned outside decided not to make
it too hot save that
it works they're going to need jobs for
lure Pramila anybody had trouble with it
no does yep
okay
yeah that's exactly right yeah
because surfing might die so if it's if
it's hanging around you can restart it
so that's one reason you can start it
again you can run Diagnostics on it so
you still got access to the lot if it's
if it's still hanging the range through
access to the logs you can still look at
the file system because remember the a
container can change its file system
it's just that when the container is is
removed those changes get lost
so you can still pin it you can still
put this file system and so it's if you
sort of got a debug your container
that's why dude that's why you'd want it
hanging around but once it once it's
stable then I always use the minus minus
RM option and is two minuses because
it's a short for remove it's not two
single flag options yep
[Music]
so the question was if I set up a
database server with access to a volume
in that set of another however many
other database servers and pointing them
at the same volume does it stop me I
don't think so but I've never tried
never looked so it's good question I
think it does but but I've never because
at the end of the day is still not you
still just another filesystem you know
still it's still room it's one of the
next kernel so he's not that isolated
then it's still being a lock tape I
don't got a separate lock table
okay does anybody may actually do the
volumes one so I create a database
example using SQL like this tea tiny bit
still illustrates the point
so what's he's doing is downing another
seeker image I created and all this does
is run sequel Lite so I'm passing a
crate table command to sequel Lite and
it straight to the table for me but I
haven't got a exam got a volume command
in there so we are then trying to run an
insert on the same table I'm sure you
can all guess what's going to happen no
such table the tables because you know
it's a different container say me of
each different container yeah so any
change I made in the first container is
gone and it can't see in the second
container so the way you do that is that
you pass a well first of all make sure
you can actually look at volumes because
they're things so there's no volume on
their volumes so now I can start running
these commands the same exactly the same
command except it's got the - - mount
option so I created a table and this
time if I do the volume and I see is
actually created a DB demo volume and so
now I could run insert on that
and it worked
and of course the select will work as
well July make sense yeah
three independent containers yep correct
and now you could just delete the volume
if you want so you know volumes the
thing I can go to curve volume RM DB DB
demo he's gone so if I try and run that
slip that's licked again no such table
that's all my data grew used volume RM
with care was the listen okay
sorry say that again you get a what okay
don't why because I make sure my duck
will my repos with private their public
okay I'll go through the material then
they'll come see it
see if anybody else gets the same
problem okay okay it's a shame alright
let's talk about environment variables
so yep
are you talking about building your
software okay so so I mean so there are
various patterns for doing that but yes
you could do that but another way would
be to actually have a have a separate
container you get cloning to build the
software and then you and then you
deploy your built software from one
container to the other so you never get
kind into production image or container
yeah make sense right passing it so
we've talked about volumes which is sort
of i/o you can read stuff and you can
write stuff we've talked about network
ports which is which is about reading
stuff and passing information back we've
got a great environment that environment
values so sort of classic you know sort
of environment strings that you passing
it
they're obviously read-only it's we're
getting information into the container
but you can't get it from a chanel which
should be you know you should use that
from the way that sub shells work so
there's a minus e option so this works
when you're doing a container run
command and you pass it a - e option so
there's an example down there and an
important point about environment
variables is that there is it's tempting
to pass secrets and other bits of
security information using environment
variables but they're not secure so
don't do that there are other mechanisms
which you'll need to go and discover to
actually relate and there are newer
mechanisms out with a very latest
release of docker to actually allow you
to securely pass secrets around when
you're building images and things like
that or running images so don't use
don't use environment roles or other
things they're quite useful so here's a
really simple example so if I run if I
run the Alpine image
Ahn's RM minus RT alpine
so notice the wonderful so just as an
aside I didn't type anything after the
Alpine so I actually got a shell in
there so I can do the usual things if I
exit from that and I used - I as RM so I
don't have to remove it but if I give it
another command like env it will run
that command and exit so that's really
useful for little demos like this so the
env commands that you don't know prints
out all my in variable values so by
default you only get four environment
variables path to home and also the
hostname okay but by using the minus
option I can pass in extra stuff so the
first example if I just type in the name
of an environment variable that will be
taken from my environment so the current
environment how's that just to prove
that let's just
so can't yell CI time is set to
Australia if I go by this e LC time then
hey presto that kind of gets a copy of
that as well okay if I want to pass
something different I just say equals
and then some other strings so e in G B
D F dot - eight and suddenly the
containers in GB locale so that's how
you parse environment variables in yep
toss trophies right you had a problem
okay that's kind of weird
I have tested these where are we the
Patrol
ah
yes different or you the angle
okay you need to fix that I'm not short
sir
so for the time being could use follow
the instruction this is the instructions
that they need to post seed in the data
repository at thanks for that and my
apologies again for the mistake
so buddy got access to that right flip
away
yeah I'm missing I'm missing a build bad
I'll fix that later today and it'll
bittle work this example by the way is
is these examples gonna get more and
more complicated and have more and more
moving parts so if the actual example
doesn't make sense because I'm using a
profile login file let me know
so just apply Anita's fix
what
it works if you make that spawn prefix
what unclench the trough 30 20 okay okay
container logs stop going is everything
that gets written to containers standard
out or standard error is considered to
be a log and docker will save it for you
for a certain amount of time it's
actually a buffer so eventually we'll
get overwritten and there's a command
called docker container logs and you
give it a reference and it will it will
spew out what it's seen so far and if
you use the - - follow option it will
behave like tail - F okay
pretty simple I'm going to skip the next
sorry that some question
are you meaning the same in the so it's
whatever's on the containers standard
out and standard in so it's whatever
whatever is is connected when you do
docker run okay very quickly we need to
talk about how to do how to create your
own images okay so you need to write a
an image you need to create a docker
file which is a list of instructions to
docker and then you run docker build so
here's an example docker file it's very
simple but it shows some important ones
the first thing is the first thing your
docker file is the base image in which
you are pulling so what will happen is
that docker will see this and it will
pull Alpine 3.8 down and will then build
all the other stuff on top of that image
you can get scratch images with
basically nothing in them okay you need
to provide some metadata so it's always
expected that you provide the maintainer
and description labels and that just
gets embedded the JSON that we saw
earlier on next is where you start doing
run command so this is actually
instruction to docker to basically
instantiate this image as a container
and then run these commands and then
store the results away as the new image
so in this case is something very simple
it's just running a package manager to
install Lua and the last thing is the
default command so this is the command
that will be run when when the when the
container starts up in this case is just
running bash sorry not bash is running
this shell and it's been running the
lower - version command okay that's what
it does now you will see a lot more in
dhaka files but this is the basic simple
stuff the other thing that you will see
which I haven't got in here is a copy so
if you look at the docker file supplied
for the last example with with the
profile files actually a copy to copy in
the profile file and that's the majority
of what you'll see the build command you
can have a default docker file name but
I prefer to use something
more descriptive and therefore I have to
use the minus F option but I always put
docker file at the end of it
you give it a friendly name so this is
called a tag and the tag includes the
tag at the end so it's a bit confusing
because the bit after the semicolon is
also called a tag so I prefer to use the
word alias for this this collection of
this string is an alias and it consists
of a name followed by a tag but to do
that you use the Manistee option okay
and the thing that you always forget is
a build context that little dot at the
end you have to give it the name of the
directory which contains all the files
that you will need to build this even if
there are none ok so if there are note
so in the previous example I'm not
copying any files in so there's no
external files needed for this example
so I have to give the name of an empty
well I can give the name of any
directory just the files won't be used
but you always have to have that
directory there so you often see a dot
and the dot is actually quite hot easy
to miss when you're reading it so be
careful
yes is the answer you but you've built
Daka contains for all sorts of purposes
and depends on your particular
environment and workflow what you were
built but you've got flexibility so you
can build whatever you want so we're
very short of time you can start this
exercise but in five minutes we'll be
moving on something else but I would
suggest you start with with task 14 and
then there are a bunch of other
follow-up tasks rate where we build more
more complex images which you can do
afterwards and ask me questions through
the get a forum is probably easiest but
go for go for 14 to ask 14 to 5 minutes
see how you get on
yes do not use the soap so you'll find
that most images have a latest tag right
so you see you know so people will
either use the term latest or they will
just leave it blank and therefore pick
up latest because that's a default don't
do that okay
are the reason for not doing that is
there it there is a convention the
latest is the current production version
that's the convention but it's just a
convention and it may be very date it
may change so you know you build suffer
on a specific version which happens to
be latest so you use the latest tank and
then next week they update the image
well they you know they they real able a
new image with the latest tag and the
old one doesn't have it anymore you
rebuild and suddenly got a different
version of your different version under
under your software and something breaks
so I don't elastic present workshop
yesterday where they said we don't use
latest and I think that's dead right but
when you are when you are building
dockerfile when you're using docker
files always explicitly put the version
that you want to use otherwise things
will change under you they have used so
know if you use latest there and you
rerun the build you get a different
version from docker hub or you risk
getting a different version so don't use
latest yes correct yes yes because it's
small and convenient so I'll pass a
popular version I did put some comments
in the workbook that Alpine is smaller
convenient have it's got a couple of
problems one is that it uses a different
package management systems the one
you're probably used to so that's a bit
fiddly a second thing is it's so small
it comes without things like it uses
busybox for the shell and things like
there are limitations so so
yeah so it's really cut down so shitty
useful for demos and for small
prototypes and that sort of thing but
I'm always using Debian when I when I'm
building this stuff tip for you is don't
use their being stretch or Jesse or
whatever use as always a slim version
which is usually about 20 Meg's smaller
so it's a bit cut down so that works
well for me
does that make sense I did say in the
abstract that I would show you docker
compose running so I feel obligated to
fulfill that contractual requirements or
I'll do that in a minute
yep you got the correct subdirectory
look make file set D you're correct
default you can't default
and today I did attend at the granite
event of the band until now but done my
job correctly
okay yeah copy works for me
so if I go docker container run
works ok duck a composed so just a quick
aside first of all I wouldn't recommend
you start using docker compose until you
understand a container build and run I'm
sorry dr. image build and document it
down around properly and understand the
nuances of docker files and running them
and so on but once you've got that then
docker compose is a useful tool because
it allows you to to to orchestrate
multiple containers not a huge number
but a few containers to create a working
system now I talked about kubernetes and
swarm being for the you know hundreds of
thousands or even hundreds or dozens
composes for the few that you need
developer working system so maybe a
database and a proxy in that this is and
that's the example I'm going to show you
and so it's quite useful and you can
actually put a lot of the information
that you would scatter into docker fast
and here and there into a single Yammer
file and just running it brings the
whole thing up for you
so I'm actually I'm actually using
somebody else's docker files glycol
Brett Fisher who runs what I think is a
very good udemy course on this what I'm
going to do is to download one of his
compose files and quick quick quick it
such as the a more fun it's specifying
the images I want to use the ports are
going to expose the environment
variables I need and all the other
processes and sequels it's a property
it's a it's a it's going to bring up a
clustered msql environment but from one
file so if I go docker compose minus F
compose three yellow it doesn't work
because I forgot something is you need a
command and so bring it up so if it
needs to or bring anything down it
doesn't need to so it's now going away
and bring up all this infrastructure for
me produces nice logs
color-coded different colors different
containers sorry
yep just from one command it's bringing
up four different containers which
includes a clustered MySQL instance and
the fact that could do that on a laptop
is quite impressive so there is so
that's it running and you know on a
little tiny laptop I brought up a fairly
complex environment it's not an
orchestration but it is a way of sort of
packaging an application a traditional
application that just needs a database
server and a thingy and in one of those
and a couple of those so for that sort
of environment it's great yes all it is
is a wrapper around all the other stuff
it's like running make is that having to
manually type CC and Lincoln that it's
just amazed it's a fancy make system for
vadhaka but in the same way that you
know you wouldn't start if you have
nervously programming you wouldn't start
from make you'd start from CC it's the
same here you need to understand the end
up what's going on underneath the hood
and I think I'm officially out of time
so if you've got any questions just
follow up online
I knew we wouldn't finish everything
because it's just too much to cover in
the length of time we got thanks for all
the questions and I really enjoyed it
you